other hotels provide relaxation luxury
and romance
our rooms provide every comfort required
by law and that was just a taste of
billy alice's giggle fits during
saturday night live i'm not bored of it
at all i love it oh don't worry everyone
could tell billy had a blast during her
snl hosting debut
and kate mckinnon kept the grammy winner
on her toes in this hotel commercial
sketch visit us and see why tripadvisor
called us a stock photo you can sleep in
and why the news called us the place
that man did those things
we put the hospital in hospitality
billy has trouble keeping a straight
face amid the marathon of jokes but she
eventually gets the job done
it's the location that will make your
uber driver say you sure
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and breakfast
and breakfast
and yogurt in a fridge that gets
padlocked at 8 59 a.m
no mercy you can look but you can't
touch
you wanted yogurt wake up at four [ __ ]
but what did billy expect when the show
kicked off with this moment in her
monologue imagine being concurrent day
colin jost
and the first thing that comes up when
you google yourself is 16 year old colin
jones and when billy wasn't breaking she
was breaking it down
watch me pop my butt okay can everybody
see my butt okay can you see that can
you see that pop it's a hip pop it's a
trunk trot hop and you feel it in your
house okay so it's truck drop pop truck
truck pop truck drop pop it's just
straight donkey christmas hip hop
how is no one filming this
billy even took her pop and locking into
the er during this tick-tock parody
oh and speaking of twerking so i'm here
to represent snl favorite miley cyrus
stopped by for a cameo in this christmas
card sketch
wait is that your friend ruth with miley
cyrus are they friends
this woman came up to my table and said
you're anna montana and then said that
she hated my music i'm just being honest
it's not for me
and of course like all of billy's
projects she made the entire night of
family affair that's what i'm saying
after billy's mom maggie popped up in
the monologue both her parents
introduced their daughter for her first
performance
ladies and gentlemen billy eilish
you call me again
drunk in your beds
driving home under the
and billy's brother slash collaborator
phineas joined her on stage for both of
the night's music acts
[Music]
but of course phineas's most memorable
moment was his quick appearance in that
hotel commercial
i will drop your bags i will scratch
your car i will watch joe rogan videos
on my phone no headphones
if you're a man i will tell you where
the strip clubs are i will offer to get
you cocaine and then i will flake i am
chaos
[Applause]
[Music]